[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sieht aus wie verletzte trend hier
genau das ist uns wahr ist dass unsere
produktionsstraße wir haben uns nach dem
prinzip von von henry ford prinzip von
henry ford und zwar eine
produktionsstraße aufgebaut und die
produktionsstraße sind ganz ganz vorne
an beim alexander beim alex zeigt was
alex macht genau für alex richtete
gläser hin
da alex richtig leser hin
dann kommt frank ist das super elf
versuche elf macht zu bereiten fraglich
zu viel
die ministerin wird immer dicker und die
andrea macht schön braunen zu bereiten
dann haben wir den cia marktes für das
salz zu stellen
genau das der markt ist das salz in der
suppe sozusagen die harley allem was
machst du ne ecke okay
der vulkan ist veganer was machst du
volkan okay sind ist vegan ist es
erlaubt
so etwa die was machst du tonkabohne
nicht so viel außer beim glas von genii
da kannst du kein schütteln weil zu viel
karbon ist giftig juni bei dem bierstand
regens gerade das ist auch der grund sie
hat 50 jahre lang eine stadt gearbeitet
deswegen so langsam
und außerdem es ist so ein schönes bild
ist das ganze bild kaputt gemacht nein
er sticht mich an machen werden wir
geben jetzt nachher wieder zurück das
geht wieder zurück
das ist in ordnung und ist eine aktion
nein an jemand anders
und hier haben wir frau weihnachtsmann
und frau bei einer weihnachtsfeier
weihnachtsfrau weihnachtsbaum 8 hinten
drauf wir übrigens auch selber gemacht
und zwar die haben alle selber gezeigt
marseille hat unser marcel selber
bezeichnet am ende ist zucker browser
sogar sind nike tonkabohne und mandeln
und was das ist jetzt nicht an wen geht
es jetzt das geht jetzt an alle freunde
und an unsere fahrer ein selbstgemachtes
geschenk zum daheim selber fertig macht
franz mandl ausgleich kommen noch die
engel die verteilen
los los elfen und rudolf gibt alles wir
müssen es schaffen vor weihnachten alles
auszuliefern
die weihnachts kutsche kommt als diese
sich 24
also muss ein teil und weil es mich
machen hat er muss die gläser wegpacken
elizabeth
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zu jedem glas gibt es noch die
selbstgemachte karte und jetzt kommt das
noch mit einer meiner verpackung kommt
es zu jedem unserer freunde oder partner
und es ist selbstgemacht ist geschenkt
und das ist etwas kurses weihnachten
etwas selber machen und deshalb
verschenken weil das wichtigste was du
hast und das wertvoll es ist eine zeit
und da haben jetzt wirklich zeit
aufgebraucht um das hier zu machen und
bis an unsere partner zu schicken und
freunde mit lustigen geschichten
[Musik]
falls ja auch gebrannte mandeln aus dem
glas zum selbermachen verschenken wollte
dann gibt es hier die anleitung dafür
nehmen wir einfach ein glas mit 500
milliliter fassungsvermögen
da kommt 60 gramm weißer zucker reis 60
gramm brauner zucker eine prise salz
eine prise gemahlene nelken einen
esslöffel oder zwei teelöffel zimt eine
prise gemahlene tonkabohne und 200 gramm
ganze mandel dann verschließt ihr das
glas wird ein etikett drauf und können
es dann gemeinsam mit dieser anleitung
verschenken
falls ihr dieses glas von uns geschenkt
bekommen habt oder von euren freunden
dann nehmen wir dieses glas steht zwar
auf der anleitung aber ist wirklich
super einfach der komplette inhalt kommt
jetzt in eine beschichtete pfanne dann
gebt ihr ungefähr 100 milliliter wasser
dazu sorgt dafür dass die gebrannten
mandeln nicht verbrennen
jetzt aufkochen lassen
und durch das wasser legt sich der
zucker richtig schön um jede einzelne
mandl ohne dass der zucker vorher
verbrennt
[Musik]
lebt seht ihr jetzt verkauft das ganze
wasser und der zucker legt sich jetzt
ganz trocken um die mandeln herum
jetzt nur nicht ausmachen jetzt stellt
ihr den herd auf mittlerer stufe und
lasst den zucker ganz langsam
karamellisieren und dann wenn du schön
glänzend dann nämlich aus der pfanne
heraus
[Musik]
guckt mal jetzt sind die gebrannten
mandeln fertig also ihr müsst einfach
nur geduldig sein und den herd auf
mittlere stufe stellen damit der zucker
nicht zu schnell verbrennt und jetzt
einfach auf dem backpapier oder einer
bank folie abkühlen lassen so ein
bisschen auseinander ziehen und jetzt
noch nicht probieren diese nehme ich
noch viel zu heiß und nach dem abkühlen
werden richtig schön knackig und die
pfanne und den teig schauer bekommt ihr
wieder sauber wenn ihr wasser rein gibt
aufkochen lassen und lässt sich so dass
zucker und das karamell
[Musik]
und was wünschen wir unseren zuschauern
und unseren freunden zu weihnachten
alles alles liebe und wir wünschen uns
dass alle menschen auf der welt ganz
lieb wäre
ob hier und jetzt müssen wir die kerze
aus led kerzen
also wir wünschen euch allen ein schönes
weihnachtsfest
ob ihr weihnachten feiert oder nicht
religiös feiern wir es auch nicht aber
wir verbringen zumindest die zeit
miteinander gehen zu unseren freunden
verbringen die zeit zu viert und holen
uns ein bisschen auskennt jeden tag
sollte man dankbar dafür hatten wir
machen das schlusswort vielleicht
nochmal samira ich und natürlich auch
murat wünschen euch jetzt vor
weihnachten und auch frohe weihnachten
von meinem gesamten team was wünschen
wir allen menschen zum weihnachtsfest
und viel liebe frieden was ist ganz
wichtig aber nicht nur in der
weihnachtszeit und liebt zu anderen
menschen ist und immer dankbar ist dafür
was man alles hat und natürlich auch
dass man was abgibt und die menschen die
es vielleicht nicht so ganz gut haben
also wir wünschen euch frohe weihnachten
egal ob es freiheit oder nicht freiheit
verbringt die zeit still mit eurer
familie und denkt immer an das
kostbarste was ihr habt sind länder und
[Musik]
ihr könnt ihr auch für scheibe
abschneiden
genau
[Musik]